bonsoir et bienvenue dans ça vous
regarde je suis ravi de vous retrouver
au sommaire ce soit l'europe l'allemagne
la pologne on va dresser le bilan de ce
sommet européen qui vient de s'achever à
versailles alors que la guerre en
ukraine entre dans sa troisième semaine
les objectifs annoncés à défaut de
mesures concrètes pour l'indépendance
énergétique le gaz russe la défense et
sur l'accueil des réfugiés qui affluent
par millions sont ils de nature à
limiter à stopper la tragédie
ukrainienne et contenir les dommages
collatéraux de cette guerre pour nous
européens l'analyse de nos invités sur
ce plateau dans un instant et puis et
puis revoilà la campagne présidentielle
il aura suffi d'une proposition d'
emmanuel macron sur les retraites pour
qu'elle soit relancé le président
candidat défend désormais le report de
l'âge légal à 65 ans position clivante
qui forcément va faire réagir sur ce
plateau ce sera tout à l'heure dans
notre grand débat enfin vos nouveaux
rendez-vous 2022 le ce calme d'abord qui
passe au crible ce soir le face à face à
zemmour pécresse sur tf1 hier soir et
puis bien sûr l'oeil de black hole
internet campagne de stéphane blakowski
comme chaque fois on est à 30 jours un
mois exactement deux premiers tours
voilà pour le menu c'est parti
[Musique]
et bienvenue à vous chers
téléspectateurs merci d'être au
rendez-vous que vont changer
concrètement les annonces plutôt les
grands objectifs annoncés aujourd'hui
par les 27 chefs d'état européens à
l'heure où poutine sèment la terreur en
ukraine et intensifie son offensive à
l'ouest du pays on va essayer de dresser
le bilan de ce sommet à versailles avec
vous ce soir richard wehrli vous l'avez
suivi attentivement soir myriam vous
revenez tout juste de versailles vous
avez suivi cette conférence de presse
emmanuel macron ursula von der leyen
pour la commission européenne et richard
michel pour le conseil européen jacques
charles michel pardonnez moi c'est
l'ancien président de s&p j'ai remué
ciel rien à voir car michel bien
évidemment vous êtes le correspondant
parisien du quotidien suisse le temps
est évidemment chroniqueur régulier dans
cette émission qu'on soir pascale
joannin bonsoir bienvenue directrice
générale de la fondation robert schuman
l'europe qui a peut-être plus progressé
en deux semaines quand plusieurs
décennies vous allez nous dire ce que ce
que vous en pensez enfin bon soir hans
stark merci d'être là êtes professeur de
civilisation allemande à la sorbonne à
paris l'allemagne qui est au coeur de ce
sommet avec un tournant stratégique sur
la défense tournant historique on va en
parler bien sûr dans cette émission mais
pour commencer elle demande à gabat nous
résume les principales décisions
déclarations des vingt-sept lors de ces
deux jours à versailles regardez c'est
une demande insistante du président
ukrainien mais pour les 27 6 l'ukraine
fait partie de la famille européenne pas
question d'adhésion rapide dans l'union
européenne
je comprends parfaitement l'émotion la
tente qui hélas ce que je veux dire
c'est que hier le le conseil européen a
exprimé un message fort et clair
sur le destin européen et le chemin
européen de crème sans ambiguïté
maintenant pouvons-nous avoir une
procédure accélérée ou exceptionnelle
avec un pays en guerre sont regardés
aucun critère la réponse est non réuni à
versailles les dirigeants européens se
sont dits prêts un quatrième volet de
sanctions contre la russie malgré les
avertissements des dirigeants du kremlin
l'union européenne persiste et signe
elle double son enveloppe pour envoyer
du matériel militaire en ukraine au
travers de la facilité paix qui mobilise
du matériel y compris militaires et une
orientation a été prise d'ajouter 500
millions d'euros additionnels à la
facilité paix dans ce cadre comme prévu
pas d'embargo sur le gaz russe mais un
agenda fixée pour que la commission
européenne détermine comment atteindre
l'indépendance d'ici à 2027 l'objectif
de réduire des deux tiers
l'approvisionnement en gaz russe d'ici
la fin de l'année reste faisable mais il
est très loin d'être acté
le n'est pas un embargo mais une
réduction en essayant de diversifier nos
sources d'approvisionnement
il faut être sûr de pouvoir importer
beaucoup plus de gaz naturel liquéfié
pour l'union européenne ces dernières
semaines nous avons travaillé dur en ce
sens nous avons appelé tous nos amis
autour du monde et nous en avons
beaucoup pour les prévenir que nous
allons avoir besoin de beaucoup plus de
gaz ce matin le président ukrainien
volodimir zelensky exhortaient l'europe
à en faire plus pour l'ukraine sûr que
cette déclaration de versailles des 27
ne réponde à ses attentes ni à celle du
peuple ukrainien
richard verrez vous qui revenait de
versailles vous avez regardé
attentivement la déclaration des
vingt-sept et assister à cette
conférence de presse franchement est-ce
que vous avez le sentiment quand on
entend le président ukrainien qu'on voit
la situation cauchemardesque d'un pays
anéantis que les annonces les
déclarations sont à à la mesure à la
hauteur de l'urgence je crois qu'elles
sont à la hauteur de ce que peut faire
l'union européenne et de ce qu'elle doit
faire dans les circonstances présentes
bien évidemment il et elles sont en deçà
de ce que veut le président ukrainien
elles sont en deçà de ce que voudraient
les ukrainiens parce qu'au fond ils
voudraient un soutien massif et total à
partir du moment où il était de toute
façon exclu que l'union européenne une
façon d'une autre ou bien l'otan frappe
la russie ou frappe l'ukraine à partir
du moment où la dépendance vis-à-vis du
gaz russe on la connaît et elle
paralyserait l'économie s'ils ont coupé
le robinet maintenant regardons ce qui a
été décidé moi j'ai été très frappée par
deux choses à versailles lors de cette
conférence de presse et avant la
première chose c'est qu'il y a vraiment
une unité européenne sur un sujet
compliqué l'ukraine c'est un sujet
compliqué rapport le tout le front
oriental l'union européenne est quand
même dans une situation très différente
de nous ici à paris la deuxième chose
c'est qu'il y à un audit généralisé au
fond c'est ça qui va être fait dans les
prochains mois par la commission pour
savoir où et comment investir pour
répondre à ce défi ukrainien c'est quand
même ce qu'il fallait et rappelons qu'il
il y aura un autre sommet européen dans
dix jours il y en aura un en juin donc
ce qu'il faut c'est que maintenant la
pression reste et que les dirigeants
accouche de ce qu'ils ont promis ce
qu'ils ont promis c'est déjà pas mal
pascale joannin l'unité rare en europe
là elle n'est pas brisé depuis le début
de l'entrée en guerre de la russie
depuis son invasion en ukraine elle est
même exceptionnel est ce que ça vous a
surpris
ou est-ce que c'est l'europe de la peur
tout simplement qui fait que voilà elle
rompt avec ses habitudes et elle parle
enfin d'une seule voix alors je sais pas
si elle parle d'une seule voix en tout
cas elle est unie puisque là on a écouté
à la fraîcheur de michel ursula von der
leyen le président français et puisque
plusieurs institutions c'est pas d'état
fédéral donc comme on dit pas un état
fédéral on n'a pas un président de
l'europe on en a plusieurs et
mais cette unité de l'europe dont vous
parlez c'est une unité des 27 membres
qui la composent elle est toujours
difficile parce que on a élargi en 2004
et a peu après et à avoir un accord à
vingt-sept on sait que c'est plus
difficile qu'à 6 quand on était au début
de la construction européenne mais en
moins depuis le 24 février il ya une
unité en effet de l'europe parce que en
effet on a une agression d'un pays
voisin la russie contre un autre pays
voisin l'ukraine sans motif justifié
sans motif justifié avec en effet des
répercussions qui sont en effet sur les
quatre pays qui ont une frontière avec
l'ukraine la pologne la slovaquie la
hongrie et la roumanie nous avons une
unité dans les décisions qui ont été
prises comme vous l'avez dit tout à
l'heure il ya eu peut-être plus qui a
été pris en quinze jours quand plusieurs
années puisqu'on a eu une unité sur les
mesures et des sanctions économiques et
elles sont au delà de ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer
il ya eu une unité également sur les
questions de défense alors tout le monde
n'a pas la même stratégie mais on voit
bien que tout le monde est d'accord pour
dire qu'il va falloir dépenser plus pour
la défense et avoir une indépendance
parce que si jamais nous avions nos
intérêts qui sont en jeu ne sont pas les
enjeux américains ils feraient pas
compter sur nos amis américains qui
depuis plus représentent la république
américaine nous dise qu'il regarde plus
vers l'asie que vers l'europe on a une
unité également sur l'accueil des
réfugiés sur les mesures humanitaires et
puis on risque d'avoir peut-être aussi
une
accord de vues sur la réduction qu'il
faut que l'on ait de la dépendance
énergétique vis à la russie tous les
pays ne sont pas dans la même situation
on voit bien que tout le monde est
d'accord pour dire qu'on ne peut plus
dépendre uniquement de la russie et
qu'il va falloir que l'on prenne des
mesures alors qu'ils vont pas être un
embargo parce qu'on est trop dépendant
on va réduire sa dans un délire
l'honneur dans le détail si bhl on va
parler de la défense on va parler de
l'énergie j'aimerais connaître au fond
en stars comment vous qualifier le
moment pour l'europe on a l'impression
que l'après guerre froide est finie que
l'europe certes unis mais se retrouve
face à un ennemi véritablement la russie
qu'elle n'a jamais véritablement
considéré comme tel et aujourd'hui c'est
davantage le cas en laine et miss et la
russie de poutine bien sûr c'est pas les
russes c'est pas les russes et c'est
important de le souligner parce que à
terme il faut espérer qu'il ya un après
poutine et que l'on retrouve le chemin
d'un dialogue constructif avec avec les
ruches heureuse qui vivent un enfer
aujourd'hui qu'ils quittent massivement
politique russe l'ex et une nouvelle
webradio million et demi d'ukrainiens
qui ont quitté leur pays à 300000 russes
qui ont quitté leur pays et beaucoup
informations liées à la guerre mais
peuvent pas parce qu'ils ont des enfants
et des grands parents et c'est donc là
c'est quand même hein c'est assez
important mais c'est une nouvelle europe
scellé la faveur de cette guerre de 24
février a tout changé le 24 février
c'est un c'est une césure majeur elle
fait partie des quelques grandes césure
que nous avons connu depuis 1914 et 14 c
39 ses 89 avec la chute du mur de berlin
c'est le 11 septembre et là c'est le 24
février donc ce sont les cinq grandes
césure géopolitique qui vont tout
changer de l'après guerre prend fin a
pris fin et nous sommes arrivés
aujourd'hui dans un monde où les
équilibres tectoniques sont en train
d'être complètement bouleversé et on ne
peut pas attendre d'un seul sommet à
versailles ou ailleurs pour tout régler
évidemment saisir l'âme et france dans
une révolution entre guillemets
révolution
et donc il faut y faire face et il faut
du temps pour ça l'union européenne donc
il n'a jamais agi avec autant de force
de vigueur et de rapidité si je si je
vous suis bien on va pas revenir sur ce
qui a été fait ces sanctions économiques
et financières
massives sur la défense 500 millions
d'euros supplémentaires sur budget
européen s'appelle la facilité
européenne de pêche fait pas de bêtise
ça c'est très nouveau pour livrer des
armes létales directement à l'ukraine ça
c'est un tournant ça peut suffire c'est
déjà ça ben c'est pas que les 500
millions s'ajoutent à des millions
d'autres 500 millions plus à des
livraisons d'armes qui ont été faites on
sait aujourd'hui que en ukraine ya
probablement quelque en parle de 17000
missiles antichars de type j'avais là
qui sont très très efficace dans le
combat contre les chars et les véhicules
blindés et six chars missiles anti
missiles anti aériens avec listings à
qui oblige les russes finalement à
bombarder des villes ukrainiennes de
très haut donc ce qui ce qui est
évidemment terrible sera terrible pour
les populations civiles parce que là du
coup il ya vraiment plus de frappes
chirurgicales possible on aura plutôt
des bombardements de type deuxième
guerre mondiale sur les villes
allemandes qui ont été visés de façon
globale et donc on entre dans une dans
une logique de guerre qui va être atroce
on entend parler aussi dans mes
chimiques et biologiques voulait qu'on
en parle puisque ont dit non à la no fly
zone c'est à dire la possibilité pour
l'europe finalement
d'empêcher les avions russes de
bombarder ça ça ferait une courbe et les
gérances entrée en guerre pareil pour
les avions c'est bien ça richard dans
les livraisons d'avions mais si les
russes utiliser les armes chimiques est
ce que ce serait une ligne rouge est-ce
que ça en coulisses à versailles vous en
avez discuté on se souvient de la ligne
rouge d'obama en syrie qui évidemment
n'a pas été respecté alors il y a une
ligne en tout cas qu'ils étaient très
claires et qui a d'ailleurs été exprimé
lors de cette conférence de presse est
un partage des tâches aujourd'hui
l'union européenne n'est pas en première
ligne pour assurer je dirais le l'effort
de guerre immédiat ou pour se coordonner
avec l'effort de guerre immédiat des
ukrainiens ça c'est l'otan et je crois
que dans cette période là aujourd'hui ce
type de décision que ce soit la zone
d'exclusion aérienne que ce soit
éventuellement la livraison d'avions
pour l'instant les américains ont refusé
ils ont refusé l'initiative polonaise
tout ça c'est du ressort de l'otan et
c'est normal parce que c'est le temps
d'ailleurs madame von der leyen la
payant de la commission a redit c'est la
plus puissante alliance militaire du
monde elle est là pour sur des germes
sinon les pays européens qui sont
membres de l'otan il faut le rappeler
vous avez la plume dames ont discuté
avec les conseillers
considère-t-il qu'il faut que l'otan
puisse intervenir en cas d'abus alors je
crois qu'il ya aujourd'hui un consensus
pour dire que si des armes chimiques
étaient utilisés en ukraine l'otan sous
une forme ou sous une autre serait
obligé de réagir cris oui j'ai pas dis
réplique ray serait obligé de réagir si
vous avez des mois je suis pas dans le
temps donc je vais pas mais il y a il y
à différentes manières de le faire ça
peut être par exemple de décréter la
zone d'exclusion aérienne nouveau pardon
vous parliez ça peut être de permettre à
ce moment là des avions
rebaptisé ukrainiens de voler dans le
ciel de craignait d'aller frapper des
convois russe mais n'oublions pas que
l'union européenne aujourd'hui et c'est
normal qu'il y ait ce partage des tâches
ça ne veut pas dire que l'union
européenne je dirais et moins courageuse
elle elle va s'occuper si elle tient ses
promesses de construire sa défense de
demain et moi j'étais frappé par une
chose c'est que le mot souveraineté vous
savez qu emmanuel macron adore il
commence à être remplacé par un autre
mot qui au fond est beaucoup plus claire
indépendance l'indépendance de l'union
européenne et ça j'ai trouvé ça très
intéressant pascal jaouen un mot sur la
pologne la pologne on parlait de l'otan
qui a toujours été tourné vers les états
unis même si elle a toujours voulu
rentrer dans l'europe pour sa sécurité
c'est clairement l'otan la haye les
plaques tournantes plaque tournante pour
les les armes qui passe par sa frontière
plaque tournante pour les réfugiés qui
traverse sa frontière dans l'autre sens
bien évidemment est-ce que la pologne
change de pied aussi dans l'europe en
disant cette fois ci on y est et on va
plus opéré de résistance alors la
pologne comme tous les états qui sont
dans l'union européenne a changé ou va
changer dans les dents dans l'est dans
les semaines ou les mois qui viennent
parce que cette situation qui était
qu'on a jamais connu enfin
[Musique]
oblige à changer de concept radicaux
alors les allemands l'ont fait sur une
certaine sur une telle chose les danois
s'interroge en effet il y aura un
référendum le 1er juin il ya les suédois
et les finlandais qui ne marque de bière
deux autres etc
comprendront-ils comme effet être sous
le joug américain
et de cette dépendance américaine
n'est pas n'est pas n'est pas une bonne
garantie parce que là en effet ils vont
certainement l'avoir mauvaise parce
qu'ils voulaient donner des mig parce
que les avions de chasse et en craignant
savent les piloter etc ils n'ont pas
voulu le faire directement parce qu'ils
sont aux premières livres ils sont
passés par les états unis qui sont
l'événement disons maintenant on le fera
pas donc ils vont peut être un effet
désiré à quoi ça sert les états unis si
on essaie de passer par vous mais on n'y
arrive pas je crois que dans cette
affaire il ya une erreur qui a été fait
dès le départ par les américains c'est
de dire qui aurait jamais de riposte et
qu'on enverrait rien moi monsieur
poutine y met des hommes à la frontière
est-ce qu'on n'aurait pas été dès que le
pour montrer à monsieur poutine qu'il
fallait pas qu'ils fassent n'importe
quoi sans qu'on aille dans la guerre qu
qu'on allait faire des manoeuvres dans
des endroits qui sont aux frontières
juste pour rappeler que ben tu joues à
l'âme et cl tu vas l'avoir
avoir de l'avoir dit de très longtemps
très loin en dix ans mais nantes sont
interviendra pas à donner aussi à
monsieur poutine un signal que bobo les
américains ne répondons pas
militairement les européens ne seraient
pas en mesure de le faire ce qui est
vrai est donc là en effet comme vous
l'avez dit richard il ya une question de
l'indépendance l'indépendance
stratégique en matière de défense pour
si jamais nos intérêts sont en jeu un
jour et que ce n'est pas les intérêts
des américains il faut qu'on est à côté
de l'otan pas contre l'autre temps
quelque chose qui nous permettra de
pouvoir agir comme on a agi aujourd'hui
avec le pouvoir qui est le nôtre
normatif économique commercial etc et
l'indépendance énergétique alors dans
les deux cas on vient on est dans les
deux cas la france a une position
particulière parce que nous on à l'ars
nucléaire
très indépendant vis-à-vis de l'otan et
sur les sur l'énergie avec le nucléaire
aussi on ne va plus indépendants mais il
ya des pays qui le sont moins alors on
espère faut qu'ils prennent conscience
que la dépendance c'est peut-être la clé
d'actions futures pour leur alors un mot
aussi sur le tournant allemand sur le
temps de la défense là aussi c'est
l'indépendance l'allemagne qui balaye en
gros combien 50 ans d'histoire géo
politique on peut dire ça et
diplomatique c'est leur choix c'était le
27 février dernier avec ce discours
historique expliquez-nous au fond qu'est
ce qui a permis cette mutation très
impressionnante sur des questions de
défense est ce que c'est la population
allemande la société civile est ce que
c'est la coalition qu est ce qu il a
fait bouger s'il y est passé pas 50 en
réalité ses 30 passes que la rupture
pour l'allemagne sur le plan militaire
c'est l'unification
avant l'unification on avait face à la
république fédérale d'allemagne
l'ancienne allemagne de l'ouest qui l
avait investit chaque année on était en
pleine guerre froide plus de 2% de son
pipe dans la défense et qui étaient en
première ligne à l'époque on parlait de
la défense de l'avant donc si jamais eu
une guerre en europe centrale les
allemands auraient été là vraiment aux
frondes quelque sorte dont qu'ils
avaient fait le nécessaire pour jouer le
jeu et pour assurer avec des moyens qui
fit l'honneur la défense européenne
la césure ou la rupture c'est
l'unification pourquoi parce que lorsque
l'allemagne signifient en 1990 on se
méfie de l'allemagne on a oublié ça
aujourd'hui à 30 ans qu'est ce qu'on
disait que l'allemagne c'est le
quatrième rice et le retour de la
puissance patati patata et donc on a
réduit la bundes faire fortement ils
étaient cinq cent mille hommes réduits à
moins ses quelques 200 donc la remise
aujourd'hui donc être fortement et des
allemands eux mêmes ont applaudi des
deux mains et était ravie parce qu'ils
sont 10 à on va toucher les dividendes
de la paix on va dépenser moins pour la
défense on fera autre chose et c'est
très bien comme ça et par ailleurs on
est entouré d'amis bien et là arrive le
réveil du 20 février les allemands se
rendre compte qu'ils ne sont plus en
tauride amis et qu'ils ont un budget de
la défense depuis maintenant une
trentaine d'années qui fait que l'armée
allemande est complètement sous
financées sous équipés et que si jamais
il devait y avait une guerre classique
territoriales ou frontières du mal à
l'allemagne ne pourrait pas se défendre
1 aujourd'hui en cas d' attaque la main
et l'allemagne ainsi samedi ses généraux
elle pourrait pas se défendre et surtout
elle pourrait pas non plus venir en aide
suffisamment à ses alliés les lacets
salle électrochoc ça veut dire que
l'allemagne arrive maintenant à une
situation telle en termes d'équipement
en termes de puissance militaire que
c'est devenu un véritable noeud
militaire et que ça comment alors là il
ya 100 milliards qui arrive et on va
monter à 2 % du pipe comme ça chez
l'église les ont dit les membres de
l'otan remonter la pente alors on va
parler de l'indépendance énergétique
pigmentaire on terminera avec un duplex
vous le verrez la frontière polonaise
avec clément perreault sur
l'indépendance énergétique pas d'embargo
personne ne s'y attendait la dépendance
européenne est trop forte notamment
allemandes et puis les pays de l'est
mais tout de même on l'indépendance à
terme c'est les bruits deux engagements
qui sont quand même pris le premier
c'est de diminuer la dépendance
énergétique des deux tiers d'ici d'ici
l'hiver prochain ça fait sûr c'est dans
la déclaration parce qu'il ya pas de
d'instance et c'est assez je ne sais pas
si j'ai un déclaration parce qu'on me
demande partir du sommet je n'ai pas pu
voir la version française c'est la
commission européenne qui coule
les lyonnais tenaient là chez le vendeur
leyen l'abbaye et des propositions
seront faites en mai pour parvenir nos
premiers premier point diminué des deux
tiers la dépendance énergétique d'ici au
prochain hiver deux tiers c'est déjà
énorme deuxième point c'est réussir en
2027 c'est-à-dire dans cinq ans cinq ans
je le rappelle c'est très long quand
vous êtes sont les sous les bombes mais
c'est pas si longue ça pour les
économies européennes c'est réussir ouf
on a coupé le robinet coupé le robinet
rangement franchement quand on regarde
la carte on y arrive oui le savoir les
pays baltes l'estonie à 93% gaz russe
lettonie 100% loterie 100% on peut y
arriver la quiche et en allemand la
douane en france et énergétiques il ya
deux gazoducs nord stream le deuxième
pour l'instant l'allemagne lamy
et elle a méprisé alors fermé ou joueurs
de diaby elle envisage aussi je parle
contrôle d'autre que même le north
stream 1 on pourrait être en effet à
arrêter celui qui est en vigueur depuis
plus longtemps donc il y a en effet là
franchement oui mais c'est allé sociaux
c'est sur la tête de la des négociations
au bundestag
il n'y a plus d'approvisionnement mais
là aujourd'hui vers la pologne
l'industrie là aujourd'hui gaza de
l'hiver est quasiment finie et donc les
besoins énergétiques pour cet hiver
c'est terminé mais si l'allemagne prend
cette décision si elle le prend je ne
sais pas si elle la prendra mais si la
france est bien qu'ils aient un
revirement considérable pour dire on ne
peut pas dire que la russie de poutine
est notre ennemi et qu'elle a et qu'on
ne peut pas supporter ce qu'elle fait et
puis lui acheter du gaz avec monnaies
sonnantes et trébuchantes
donc il faut bien être en rapport avec
ses ambitions
donc on peut pas le faire radicalement
messi déjà pour prévoir l'hiver prochain
on ne met pas nos amis européens qui
sont dépendants aujourd'hui dans des
conditions de chauffage ou de dell
d'accès l'énergie difficile il faut
prendre les mesures tout de suite pour
pouvoir essayer de faire en sorte qu' on
puisse avoir quelque chose pour la
situation 2023 d'hiver 2022 2023 tout de
suite et pour les gazoducs en effet
avant de pouvoir les construire ou les
ralliés l'existant va faire un peu
d'investissements il ya peut-être un
ballon qui va être un plan drague art
âgées à venir un plan nouveaux qui
viennent ford europe d'art aider les
pays qui ont besoin peut-être de faire
de l'investissement énergétique parce
qu'il va pas retrouver d'autres
fournisseurs y en a peut-être que les
autres pour nous aussi tout ça y est
mangane baisser le chauffage et essayer
exactement d'avoir alors au niveau des
effets sur la dépendance au gaz russe on
avance parce que je voudrais qu'on
termine avec la question des réfugiés ou
j'aurais bien sûr la carte et la pologne
on le disait qui est en première ligne
c'est le premier pays d'accueil vous le
voyez la frontière à l'ouest avec
l'ukraine les réfugiés qui affluent en
masse on est à plus de deux millions de
réfugiés un million et demi qui sont
passés par la frontière polonaise et
c'est là que se trouve clément perreault
envoyé spécial pour lcp qui va nous
décrire la situation de ces familles
souvent des femmes souvent des enfants
qui ont réussi à fuir
je trouve ici à la frontière entre la
pologne et
et nation va droit que vous pouvez voir
les réfugiés ukrainien qui viennent
d'arriver à pied de la frontière et
qu'ils rentrent donc ici sur le
territoire européen
à leur arrivée il y a le tout de suite
une prise en charge humanitaire avec des
vêtements de la nourriture également des
services de premiers soins on voit ici
les humanitaires venus vraiment de
presque tous les pays d'europe on va
pouvoir des français des allemands
également l'un des britanniques qui sont
là et bien sûr des polonais une fois
qu'ils ont passé mais cette première
étape il ya les réfugiés sont envoyés à
quelques kilomètres de là et dans une
ville un peu plus grande ou un autre
centre les accueille toujours avec des
humanitaires qui pour la plupart et bien
fondées initiative personnelle se
regroupent ensemble pour accueillir ces
réfugiés beaucoup d'associations
également et là aussi on voit vraiment
des représentants de tous les pays
européens et cette aide humanitaire pour
le moment elle tient et elle tient
beaucoup grâce à ses bénévoles pour ce
qui est du travail du gouvernement
polonais on peut dire qu'ils facilitent
le travail des humanitaires mais il n'ya
pas encore réellement de structures
d'état importante dans la prise en
charge de ces réfugiés ce que l'on peut
voir ici en plein ce que l'on peut lire
également dans l après c'est que et bien
le gouvernement conservateur polonais
redoute que cet afflux ne deviennent
plus importants dans les prochains jours
dans les prochaines semaines et que la
pologne un seul et du mal à gérer cet
afflux est donc il va sans doute y avoir
la pression qui sera mise par les
autorités polonaises sur l'ensemble des
pays membres de l'ue eux pour qu'ils
participent eux aussi à l'effort
d'accueil de se réfugier en star que la
pologne est exactement dans la même
situation à laquelle étaient l'allemagne
quand elle a fait venir accepté
plus d'un million de réfugiés on
entendait clément pernot préciser que
c'est la générosité surtout des polonais
le gouvernement un peu plus inquiet on
sait que la pologne c'est ce parti le
pis conservateur en qu'illustre
populiste anti migrants mon souvient
évidemment de la crise avec la
biélorussie vous pensez que ça peut
continuer cette solidarité européenne va
fonctionner on sur la question des
réfugiés très très certainement parce
que les polonais se sont depuis toujours
très très proche les ukrainiens et
partage beaucoup de choses avec eux
et les longs humanitaire des polonais
est important c'est un pays la pologne
c'est 40 millions d'habitants donc ils
ont accueilli là aujourd'hui deux
millions et demi donc non pas de deux
sur les deux millions et demi de
réfugiés 1,5 est arrivé en pologne alors
que l'allemagne a accueilli 1 millions
pour une population totale de 80
millions d'habitants donc l'effort du
côté polonais vraiment absolument
considérable d'autant que nous ne sommes
qu'au début de cette guerre ce qui veut
dire que ça va il se met à suivre une
cure parce qu'on pourra compter sur la
solidarité des vingt-sept l'esprit que
chacun laisse aller à part comme on dit
en la sincérité des 27 est totale parce
que c'est une hier on faut aider les
personnes qui sont aux réfugiés et
déplacés etc j'ajoute qu'au delà des
quatre états membres dont on a parlé
tout à l'heure kira kira qui ont des
réfugiés et la moldavie qui est pas dans
l'union européenne qui ce petit étang
entre l'israël
qui ont en effet à compte tenu de sa
population qui est beaucoup moindre a en
effet eu un flot de réfugiés qui est
beaucoup plus supérieur à auto du du sud
de la pologne donc en effet il va
falloir aider aussi la moldavie parce
que ces réfugiés ils n'ont pas vocation
à rester éternellement là ils voudront
rentrer dans leur pays quand ça sera
possible et quand ça sera possible et on
voit bien aussi que maintenant il ya des
pays de l'ouest qui accueille aussi
quelques réfugiés parce que les gens
veulent partir et essayer de trouver une
solution pour les quelques années qui
viennent sans doute parce que je pense
qu'on est plutôt dans ce train de là que
sur des semaines merci beaucoup merci à
tous les deux d'être venu commenter un
peu à chaud d'une certaine manière ce
sommet informel de versailles dont on
comprend que vous considérez que voilà
il est substantiel dans la ligne droite
des des premières sanctions décision
européenne merci à tous les deux on va
s'arrêter à présent sur une proposition
qui relance la campagne présidentielle
hier emmanuel macron par la voix de sa
garde rapprochée a fait connaître son
programme sur les retraites si le
président est réélu il va falloir
travailler plus longtemps beaucoup plus
longtemps jusqu'à 65 ans le nouvel âge
légal de départ qu'il propose de quoi
permettre aux autres candidats est bien
de faire entendre immédiatement leurs
réactions et surtout leurs propres
propositions alors qu'ils proposent quoi
on voit cela avec marco pommier
c'est tout pour une priorité pour
emmanuel macron la réforme des retraites
le président candidat veut repousser
progressivement l'âge de départ de 62 à
65 ans confirmation hier de son
entourage il nous faut collectivement
travailler plus pour produire plus de
richesses afin de financer notre modèle
social autre mesure annoncée la fin des
principaux régimes spéciaux et une
pension minimum de 1100 euros pour une
carrière complète
pour valérie pécresse se serait 1200
euros par mois la candidate des
républicains qui souhaite aussi un
départ à 65 ans mais d'ici 2030 contre
2032 pour emmanuel macron les deux
candidats promettent de prendre en
compte les carrières longues et la
pénibilité comme eric zemmour qui
propose 64 ans comme âge de départ le
système de répartition et par danger
puisque nous avons de moins en moins de
cotisants pour de plus en plus de
retraités relever l'âge de la retraite
marine le pen y est opposée elle préfère
un système progressif en fonction de
l'âge et du nombre de trimestres plus
l'âge d'entrée dans l'emploi sera bas
plus le nombre de trimestres nécessaires
pour bénéficier du taux plein sera lui
aussi faible concrètement les français
entré dans la vie active avant 20 ans
pourront partir à 60 ans avec 40
annuités mais à partir de 25 ans rien ne
change il faudra cotiser 42 annuités
comme aujourd'hui la candidate du
rassemblement national formule deux
autres promesses ré indexation des
retraites sur l'inflation et
revalorisation du minimum vieillesse à
1000 euros par mois contre 900
aujourd'hui
proposition similaire à gauche chez anne
hidalgo la maire de paris qui entend
aussi porter le minimum contributif à
1200 euros quant à l'âge de départ
d'abord il n'ya pas un problème de
soutenabilité
du financement de notre régime des
retraites et ça le conseil d'orientation
des retraites le dis très clairement je
garantis la retraite à 62 ans maintenir
l'âge actuel c'est aussi le souhait de
yannick jadot nicolas dupont aignan et
de jean lassalle ils vont remettre le
travail à la mode oui on a détruit
l'idée du travail au niveau de nos
compatriotes le travail doit être
revalorisé autre son de cloche ceux des
partisans de la retraite à 60 ans
philippe poutou nathalie arthaud fabien
roussel ou encore jean luc mélenchon
l'insoumis propose le retour à 40
annuités pour bénéficier d'une retraite
à taux plein mais quid du financement en
a quand même qui les salaires des femmes
au niveau de ceux des hommes et les
cotisations sociales supplémentaires
paye la différence jean luc mélenchon
promet aussi l'équivalent d'un smic
revalorisé à 1400 euros pour une pension
minimum
bonsoir roland lescure et bienvenue sur
ce plateau député alaa public en marche
et président de la commission des
affaires économiques beau il ya plus de
session parlementaire mais vous êtes va
quand même auditionné bruno le maire sur
le plan de résilience la semaine
prochaine très bienvenue à travailler
bonsoir c'est le cas reste soit réputé
les républicains du val de marne soutien
de valérie pécresse qui elle aussi
propose d'allonger l'âge de départ à 65
ans et bonsoir thomas porte merci d'être
avec nous est membre de l'union
populaire de jean luc mélenchon qui veut
lui on l'a vu la retraite à 60 ans vous
êtes aussi cheminot syndicaliste cgt est
intéressant parce que il ya aussi un
débat dans cette réforme sur les régimes
spéciaux de retraite et vous avez je
crois rejoint jean luc mélenchon après
avoir été porte-parole de sandrine
rousseau lors de la campagne pour la
primaire d'europe écologie les verts
alors évidemment je vais commencer avec
vous roland lescure d'abord à un point
de méthodes président candidat qui fait
annoncer un élément aussi important à 65
ans qui va toucher les français je sais
qu'ils soient attentifs à cet âge de
départ par sa garde rapprochée le porte
parole du gouvernement le président de
l'assemblée est ce que c'est une une
habitude auxquels il faut voilà sata
s'attacher pour la suite c'est un
élément programme il va le faire
lui-même il est né comme ça il l'a fait
confirmer ça vous a pas échappé il ya eu
une information qui visiblement a fuité
mercredi jeudi et vendredi
hier et aujourd'hui il était au sommet
européen de versailles non c'est vrai
qu'il était président et qu'il avait pas
beaucoup le temps d'être candidat et
donc c'est richard ferrand expliqué même
le candidat c'est sûr oui oui j'en doute
pas mais je pense que cela change a fait
un bon boulot c'est déjà plus que les
fameux 64 vous souvenez de l'âge pivot
qui avait déchiré votre majorité les
marcheurs à l'assemblée si si il y avait
des tensions s'en souvient 64 ans était
poussé par edouard philippe sur la
réforme des retraites qui a été
abandonné et on se demande au fond
qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui l'a fait
changer d'avis mais d'abord c'est la
crise quand même donc on a aujourd'hui
contrairement à ce que disait un certain
tout à l'heure à votre écran un vrai
déficit du régime des retraites à peu
près 13 milliards d'euros qui fit
mystère avant aussi qui a été bouclé par
la crise évidemment on a eu une forte
chute de l'emploi même si elle a duré
peu de temps grâce à une politique de
relance donc on a un déficit aujourd'hui
il n'existait pas en 2017 je vous
rappelle que le corps le comité dans
l'intention conseil d'orientation des
retraites le dizet qui avait pas de
problème de financement des retraites en
après 2017 quand il a mis en oeuvre
finalement c'est 49 3 et bien il y était
finalement abandonnée et on se retrouve
aujourd'hui grosse tension dans l'air
donc on se retrouve aujourd'hui avec une
équation assez simple ce qu'on appelle
le pacte des générations de pâques de
solidarité c'est que ceux qui
travaillent financent à la fois
l'éducation des jeunes la retraite des
anciens et l'autonomie des treize
anciens donc aujourd'hui on a moins de
monde qu'en 1981 par exemple j'ai
entendu jean luc mélenchon prenaient
leur tour à la à la retraite à 60 ans ça
c'est mitterrand c'est 1980 la france de
2021 ce n'est plus la france de 1980 il
ya aujourd'hui 5 millions d'actifs en
plus en france il ya 10 millions de
retraités en plus donc il faut moins
d'actifs pour plus de retraités on a
besoin de travailler davantage pour
financer cette retraite pour équilibrer
le système le calcul montre qu'il faut
travailler jusqu'à 65 ans il faudra
évidemment tenir compte des retraites
des parents mais car il y ait des
carrières populaire
c'est j'allais dire malheureusement
c'est du sérieux ma retraite et si on
veut pouvoir financer les retraites et
l'autonomie il va falloir que ceux qui
travaillent travaille davantage
10 voulait financer la dépendance avec
cette réforme au passage quelques est-ce
que voilà ce sera possible s'il caresse
65 ans ça tombe bien c'est ce que
propose valérie pécresse attention à ce
que il vous coupent pas l'herbe sous le
pied là emmanuel macron nom emmanuel
vrac on reprend exactement la
proposition qui est celle de valérie
pécresse la proposition qui était aussi
la nôtre quand il ya eu le débat en
début 2020 sur la réforme dite macron
vous savez ce système universel à point
qui était à la fois injuste et surtout
auquel personne ne comprenait rien
exposition notre proposition elle était
très clair à partir du moment où
l'espérance de vie s'accroît où on a de
plus en plus de chances de rester
longtemps à la retraite ou le nombre de
retraités comme roland lescure viens de
le dire par rapport à 1980 fortement
progressé et où sont les actifs qui paye
les retraites parce qu'on est dans un
système de répartition auquel on tient
bon la bonne la bonne solution c'est
d'accepter même si c'est dur je
comprends que ce soit très dur mais
accepter de travailler plus longtemps de
caen alors à 65 ans nous nous avons fait
cette réforme déjà en 2010 la réforme
sarkozy on est passé de 60 à 62 ans ça a
été très dur il ya eu des millions de
personnes dans la rue mais au moins on a
pu l'expliquer est ce que je regrette
ces cinq années viennent de s'écouler
depuis 2017 et alors qu'il était
indispensable de mettre en place cette
réforme il s'est rien passé alors moi je
suis finalement bon satisfait que
emmanuel macron se rallie à la
proposition de valeur bien séparées à 35
ans ces soirées dès 2020 de cesser
progressivement sur ces 37 une
transition jusqu'en 2032 enfin les deux
projets sont extrêmement voisins mais je
voudrais poser à ce stade une question à
roland lescure puisque emmanuel macron
mais puisque emmanuel macron se rallient
à cette proposition de valérie pécresse
est ce que demain il va se rallier à sa
proposition sur
la sécurité sur l'impunité zéro est-ce
qu'il va se rallier à sa proposition sur
les quotas en matière d'immigration
est-ce qu'il va se rallier à sa
proposition sur le
bon chemin il est en bon chemin et met
en route et l'ironie de mon collègue
carrese on se rallie à qui ce soit on
fait aujourd'hui un travail de fond pour
élaborer un programme complet qu'on est
en train de présenter jour après jour il
a commencé lundi avec le triplement de
la prime macron et des mesures de
pouvoir d'achat par exemple la fin de la
redevance connaissait de temps
exactement en face sur les retraites
c'est pas si
est en fait une saint servais
d'équilibrer le système accroît bien
compris
l'ordre d'une quinzaine de milliards fin
on est on est donc un peu dans les mêmes
ordres de les chiffres ne mentent pas
morte vous vous défendez avec jean luc
mélenchon tout le contraire le retour de
la retraite à 60 ans à taux plein alors
jean-luc mélenchon ne cesse de répéter à
65 ans 30% des plus pauvres sont déjà
morts c'est sa grande phrase on sent
bien que il veut aider les travailleurs
pauvres à avoir une retraite à 60 ans
est ce que au fond c'est raisonnable de
dire 60 ans pour tous pourquoi ne pas
cibler justement sur ces travailleurs
pauvres ceux qui ont commencé très tôt
ceux qui ont un travail très pénible
comment vous allez financer ses 60 ans
pour tous vous avez raison de rappeler
nous notre proposition c'est la retraite
à 60 ans avec 40 annuités avec un smic
qui sera de 1400 euros net parce que
c'est aussi la proposition de notre
programme est tout à l'heure vous
évoquer la question du financement temps
nous mais toujours sur la table quand il
s'agit de nos propositions c'est entre
20 et 30 milliards mais l'institut
montaigne 10 - 20 7 milliards d'eur nous
notre solution aujourd'hui pour financer
cette réforme a un rétablissement
qualité de salaires entre les femmes et
les hommes ce qui devrait même plus être
au coeur du débat temps c'est un
scandale absolu qu'il n'y ait pas ces
qualités bien sûr ça permet de rétablir
les cotisations donc de financer le
système nous on prévoit de mettre en
place un million d'emplois avec la règle
ouverte et la planification écologique
quand vous embaucher des gens il ya de
plus en plus de cotisations et aussi la
troisième carte qu'on a vous cotisez en
fonction de vos l'air est aujourd'hui au
dessus de 3500 euros c'est moins
progressif nous on assume de dire qu'on
ira chercher sur les hauts salaires vous
avez parlé tout à l'heure de solidarité
nationale je crois que c'est aussi à
celle de ceux qui gagnent beaucoup
d'argent de participer à un système qui
permet à celles et ceux qui souffrent de
partir à la retraite à taux plein parce
qu'on est quand même vous avez parlé
d'une france du passé mais aujourd'hui
l'espérance de vie elle est à peu près
en bonne santé entre 63 et 64 ans elle a
augmenté pendant plusieurs années elle
stagne aujourd'hui donc on demande à des
gens de partir la retraite alors que
l'espérance de vie en bonne santé
baissent crois que c'est passé
vos deux candidats mélenchon pécresse
son coude à coude dans les sondages
aujourd'hui à 60 ans qu'est ce que vous
répondez alors moi ce que je réponds
c'est que il faut porter l'âge légal à
65 ans mais ça doit être accompagné de
mesures beaucoup plus favorables
qu'aujourd'hui sur la pénibilité gère
les carrières longues et puis également
sur le minimum vieillesse qu'on souhaite
porter pour une carrière à travers sur
les 60 ans c'est folie c'est pas
possible ça n'est pas possible pour
grimper pour tout simplement on a trois
mille milliards d'euros de dette le
système comme l'a dit roland lescure
aujourd'hui il est déficitaire d'une
douzaine de quinzaine de milliards par
an et donc si on veut maintenir le
système
il faut absolument leur équilibre et on
ne peut pas financer les retraites
pensions de retraite on ne peut pas le
faire par la dette on ne peut pas la
faire vous savez la dette c'est
exactement comme l'énergie
c'est une question de souveraineté quand
vous êtes endettés vous êtes obligés de
mendier auprès des prêteurs le jour où
les prêteurs ne nous prêtent plus comme
ça a été le cas pour l'italie pour
l'espagne a pas si longtemps eh bien on
se retrouve dans une situation terrible
donc nous ce que nous voulons par
rapport à vous ce que nous voulons c'est
le protéger ce système de retraites
c'est le maintenir ses maintenir notre
modèle social et pour ça il faut axer
quand même que thomas porte répond
la parole la dette de quoi qu'il en
coûte à déjà m creuser la dette est-ce
que c'est raisonnable est ce que il ya
des marchés financiers qui regardent
aussi notre notre note celle de la
france les prêteurs est ce qu'on peut
continuer à voilà à être crédible avec
cette mesure là je n'allais pas me
contredire mais aujourd'hui la france
n'est absolument pas en difficultés pour
emprunter de l'argent tout le monde lui
prêtent de l'argent et vous savez quand
on veut mettre des réformes en place on
nous sort toujours l'argument de la
dette qui dit il n'y a pas d'argent on
c'est dans ce pays qu'il y a les moyens
de faire autrement je l'expliqué nous on
ne dit pas qu'il n'y a pas un mais des
solutions sur la table pour dire il ya
un souci aujourd'hui avec le financement
on le résout avec trois ou quatre
solutions c'est possible mais derrière
la le la question de la réforme des
retraites c'est aussi quel projet de
société on veut qu'ils se posent la
retraite c'est pas un cadeau qu'on fait
aux salariés c'est des gens qui ont
cotisé toute leur vie qui doivent partir
et qui vont continuer à servir la
société avec l'engagement associatif
allait s'occuper des petits enfants à
l'école donc il faut permettre à ces
gens là d'avoir une recette et 60 ans je
le dis si c'est possible d'ailleurs un
sondage du jdd il ya quelques semaines
dit que 77 % des françaises et français
la retraite
on avance sur les régimes spéciaux on
n'y touche pas j'imagine alors ça c'est
sa crosse en france parce que les
français là vous parlez des 60 ans mais
ils comprennent pas non plus d'une
équité sur les régions il faudrait un
système plus juste on m'a déjà il ya
aucun cheminots quasiment aujourd'hui
qui part à la retraite à l'âge qui s'en
va c'est sur tous les plateaux télé
notamment est ce qu'on a appelé la
décote est avec les différentes réformes
du ferroviaire nous on veut niveler par
le haut et pas niveler par le bas donc
évidemment quand vous allez montrer
voulait garder les régimes spéciaux sûr
qu'on va garder nos jeunes spéciaux qui
sont financés d'ailleurs par des
cotisations parce que les cheminots
comme ce financier petit france c'est
faux
tous les ans on vote plusieurs milliards
de subventions
sur vous est financé par l'impôt des
autres français a la ratp où aller senso
mais c'est surtout n'est plus adapté aux
carrières telles qu'elles sont
aujourd'hui moi ma mère a travaillé la
ratp allait rentrer à la ratp à 20 ans
elle avait sorti 37 ans admis 37 ans et
demi plus tard avec une retraite à taux
plein c'était il ya vingt ans
aujourd'hui les jeunes qui rentrent à la
ratp iront peut-être faire une partie de
leur carrière dans les bus à nantes ou
ailleurs donc ces régimes spéciaux qui
sont totalement solidifier injuste et
qui ne concerne qu'une partie infime de
la population pour des raisons d'aller
déjà les mais supprimée dans la juger
entre
mais bien sur
la réforme de la sncf elle est
intéressante de ce coin sur les montants
minimum de pension parlons on a parlé un
peu des carrières longues la pénibilité
valérie pécresse emmanuel macron vont en
tenir compte en revanche une petite
différence sur le minimum 1100 euros
finalement vous les 1000 euros
finalement ses 1100 euros pour une
carrière complète 1000 euros pour
valérie pécresse non non c'est 1002 un
peu plus de 1200 x et le sait le smic
c'est bon un peu de choses près bon si
c'est pareil dollars vous avez la même
réforme des retraites manifestement
les bonnes idées sont là pour être
partagée si on peut créer du sujet en
sus autour d'un sujet oui très
importants comme celui là alors moi je
suis pour
100 euros permettent oui on tenu
notamment de la pénibilité des carrières
longues qui reste à négocier mais qu'on
a intégré dans le calcul en gros on a un
déficit de 13 milliards aujourd'hui on
crée 15 milliards de surplus
supplémentaires grâce à cette réforme ce
qui laisse à peu près de 2 milliards de
surplus en plus pour financer une partie
des enjeux de dépendances y'a pas de
secret il n'y a pas d'argent mais des
milliards insuffisant la dépendance ont
il en faut dix ans pour
couvrir dire c'est que quand on a
imaginé ce système universel par points
c'est vrai j'étais séduit
intellectuellement mais je me suis vite
rendu compte d'une chose c'est que l'on
pouvait pas l'expliquer alors que cette
réforme bon on augmente l'âge de
retraite elle c'est dur à entendre je
comprends mais on peut l'expliquer dans
une réunion publique vous pouvez
expliquer et les gens vous écoute sont
pas forcément d'accord nous écoutent ils
comprennent que dès lors qu'on vit
beaucoup plus longtemps il faut et qu'on
veut avoir une retraite décente que la
retraite doit vous permettre d'avoir un
pouvoir d'achat suffisant il faut
accepter de travailler plus longtemps
alors je loin de la fin mai que aussitôt
il faut faire attention à ceux qui sont
vulnérables à ceux qui ont eu des
carrières longues des carrières pénibles
et il faut donner un minimum vieillesse
pour quelqu'un qui a travaillé toute sa
vie qui lui permettent vraiment de vivre
dignement et vu comme apport c'est vous
qui aurez le mot de la fin que même
marine le pen qui était sur les 60 ans a
modifié substantiellement sa proposition
en disant 60 ans uniquement quand on
avait 40 annuités est ce que vous n'avez
pas l'impression que c'est le talon
d'achille cette proposition non je crois
que c'est au contraire une ligne
importante dans notre programme et qui
avec la philosophie du programme qui
selui apprendre de solidarité et
j'entends le présent dans la pluie qui
dit il faut travailler plus longtemps
parce qu'on vit plus longtemps mais il
faut aussi mesurer l'espérance de vie
qu'il ya entre les ouvriers et les
cadres on estime aujourd'hui que ces six
ans de différence entre un ouvrier et un
cadre donc nous ce qu'on propose et je
le redis ici c'est finançable c'est
financé et on a les missions du
chiffrage qui va présenter toutes nos
propositions demain en direct où l'on
lit bien la chance viendra en parler
c'est la retraite à 60 ans avec 40
annuités et 1400 euros net par mois
c'est très clair chacun a pu défendre
ses arguments quelque chose je me dis
que même en 30 jours puisqu'il reste à
peine un mois avant le choix des
français pour le premier tour vous aurez
le temps de faire à nouveau de
l'accompagner de la pédagogie merci à
vous allez on passe au scan à présent
avec nos décrypteurs c'est le rendez
vous présidentiel qui continue on passe
au crible vous allez voir ce soir le
débat zemmour pécresse d'hier soir
regardez
[Musique]
mais avant l'e3 il y aller devant
fatalité au grand remplacement
de la môle vous propose le rouge
d'helmand d'agir pour le climat
l'assimilation
la république c'est moi la prendre
orange ma chronique
[Musique]
haweij aux travailleurs le système vous
exclus il ya un vrai problème de pouvoir
d'achat rendre à la france sa grandeur
car ça c'est la fin de l'histoire c'est
de bol
alors sur ce plateau ce soir 3 scanner
on peut les appeler comme ça en tout cas
journaliste chroniqueur politologue je
commence par vous thierry vedel
bienvenue sur ce plateau un visage
nouveau dans cette ce nouveau rendez
vous est politologue chercheur au
cevipof
on retrouve isabelle bien sûr isabelle
lasserre et sa belle chevelure
excellente page du du figaro
diplomatique défileront intrigue qui a
et qui a je le rappelle fait un livre
important qui est partout d'ailleurs ça
j'espère que ça marche bien pour vous
macron le décrypteur le geass rupteur
pardonnez-moi aux éditions
d'observatoire pour tout comprendre de
la politique internationale et du bilan
du chef de l'état ont commencé avec vous
stéphane l'oeil de blacko comme chaque
soir qu'est ce qui a attiré votre oeil
ce soir alors pour tout vous dire
aujourd'hui plutôt voit la journée
commence le matin je sais pas vous mais
en tout cas ce matin j'avais l'oeil rivé
sur le compte twitter de renaud muselier
parce que je ne sais pas si vous
souvenez mais mercredi renaud muselier
disait m me pécresse va se faire
massacrer ses mots on n'en fera qu'une
bouchée or hier et ben pécresse elle a
rendu coup pour coup c'était assez serré
finalement c'était pas donc je me disais
est ce que musulin ferrain un petit mais
accule par reconnaître un mauvais
pronostic bon apparemment il avait autre
chose à faire alors rien lui qui l'a
gagnée selon vous ce face à face alors
là je ne suis pas un expert du niveau i
label halal a soutenu christine goll
franchement c'est difficile comment dire
qui est le ou la gagnante pour les
départager vois moi si j'essaye d'être
objectif gérer deux ex-aequo c'est
maquereau et le pen en fait ah bon
vous êtes déjà disputé sur un parking
pour une place avec quelqu'un c'est à
peu près le niveau du débat hier soir
dont aucun des deux évidemment des aînés
sortis grandis maintenant si vous voulez
absolument départager on est quatre on
regarde un extrait et puis après on vote
vous me direz quel était le plus
convaincant on regarde maintenant
proximité de kurram elle et c'est moi
finir
vous entendre dire
je ne vous ai pas
et oui je sais ça vous embête jeu c'est
léger comme vous ambitieuse et
non non madame pécresse nous écouter
mais aussi vous avez dit oui mesdames il
est mais j'ai dit contraire
alors vous votez bardet extraordinaire
puisque a pas de coupe un bras
d'honneur pour le répéter bon alors vous
êtes convaincu match nul 10-10 alors je
vous pourrez même surenchéri verra même
plus ce match complètement nul moi
j'aimerais vraiment pas à mettre à la
place de gilles bouleau est votée créait
fortin entendons nous si on me propose
de présenter 20 heures de tf1 si on me
propose une tranche info sur lci je veux
bien examiner la proposition faudra
s'aligner sur les salaires de lcp
évidemment mais tout cas hier soir
j'aurais pas voulu être à leur place
sauf que quand les gens se dispute sur
un parking on n'arrive jamais à les
calmer alors attention on n'y comprend
rien mais on écoute quand même
attendu
[Musique]
industrie ne parlerai pas de voter non
s'il vous plaît mais c'est pas évident 1
ce rôle a fait le tour des arbitres dans
ce genre de de déballer les autres
candidats comme ont-ils réagi basculer à
part se réjouir ja pas trop quel autre
réaction ils peuvent avoir pour ce que
mc ronsard fut enfin pas dans sa balle
il son refus de participer au débat il
pousse déjà à deux c'était le bon comme
on dit donc à 12 imaginer côté orange
ira même en jubilant fait parce que je
pas si vous souvenez mais pour se moquer
beaucoup du débat raté 2
jean marie le pen contre maquereau en
2017 et ce gif à qui circulaient ces
gestes qu'elle se mettait un fils sont
là partout dans les camps il se trouve
que hier soir des bourses est lui aussi
parti un peu dans des gestes un peu
bizarre on mettait ça un peu sur le même
palier donc ça fait un peu de finesse
bon cela dit sarkozy ressemble et lui
même à de funès il a quand même été élu
président de la république donc ça ne
disqualifie pas forcément un mais bon
oui alors sauf que là dans les sondages
zemmour pourrait être dépassé par jean
luc mélenchon a fait remarquer vous
aussi alors vous êtes exactement sur la
même ligne que le front national qui eux
aussi remarquablement nationale
enfin bon toujours est il que ce matin
david rachline lui publié un petit tweet
en disant si mélenchon se retrouve au
deuxième tour il faut faire unités de la
droite nationale donc aux filles de
mandate zemmour de retirer sa
candidature ans en faveur de l'open bon
est-ce que ça va arriver je crois pas
non alors qu compenser les candidats de
gauche de tous voilà vous me demandez
une belle de la gauche parce que je n'ai
pas pareil je comprends bien écouter à
gauche mélenchon a frappé un grand coup
il a décidé de taxer à 90% les hauts
revenus ceux qui gagnent plus de 32000
euros par mois
90 personnes ne sursaute sur ce plateau
je vois qu'on n'est pas concerné
magnétoscope 90% ça fait sursauter mais
bon tu reviens ne sont pas moins en 2010
alors on a à droite
en 2017 le figaro sursautait est vrai
qu'en 2022 il sursaute encore mais c'est
la même proposition position de
mélenchon maintien simplement voyez donc
rien n'a changé mais effectivement il
est possible qu'ils se qualifient pour
le second tour si on a le temps je vous
rajoute une petite brève sur hidalgo
rapidement alors qu'à écouter l'hymne
iceberg on a droit lui des nez quand
même la parole elle posait une question
ce matin faisait mais comment se fait-il
que le débat zemmour et pécresse est
passé la moitié du temps sur
l'immigration alors qu'il ya tellement
d'autres sujets qui intéressent le
pouvoir d'achat la santé le
réchauffement climatique est le plus à
son coup de gueule en écoute qu'on
arrête de nous bassiner avec ce sujet de
l'immigration je viens de l'immigration
n'est très nombreux à venir de
l'immigration a adoré notre pays à être
très très fier de ce fait impossible
d'en laisser dans certains quartiers
c'est sûrement très vrai pour beaucoup
de gens et ça le serait encore plus si
l'intégration était mieux travailler bah
c'est pas faux ce qu'elle dit je ne
comprends pas pourquoi elle est en
dessous des 2% pour elles mêmes après
après jean lassalle merci beaucoup
stéphane alors justement avec vous
thierry vedel on va continuer à parler
de ce débat c'est vrai que quand on
regarde ça la foire d'empoigné brouhaha
c'est inaudible on se dit mais au fond
c'est insupportable à quoi servent tous
tous ces débats les candidats en réclame
toujours plus est-ce qu'ils sont
véritablement utile tout à fait c'est
tout à fait l'impression qu'on a très
souvent après les débats on se dit ça
sert à rien c'est du brouhaha une cour
d'école des gamins et mêmes ça dégrade
l'image de la politique et pourtant on
continue on en fait toujours aimé les
candidats disent on en veut alors on
s'intéresse à la question depuis depuis
très longtemps depuis le fameux débat de
kennedy et
et nixon en 1960 et depuis lors se
demande si ça sert à quelque chose et en
particulier si c'est un impact sur les
résultats électoraux est ce que ça va
changer la vie des électeurs et en
france on a souvent l'impression que oui
parce qu on se souvient de parfois de
certaines répliques célèbres par exemple
le fameux vous n'avez pas le monopole du
coeur de
vge de valéry giscard d'estaing en 74
qui aurait pu peut-être le faire garder
le gagner pardon en contre françois
mitterrand
donc on a vraiment cette impression
alors qu'est ce que nous disent les
recherches ont fait elles nous disent
surtout d'abord que ceux qui regardent
et celles qui regardent les débats
politiques sont déjà en politisé des
gens qui sont déjà politisés qui ont des
convictions et que les débats vont
surtout conforter nos préférences
politiques et que ça va vraiment très
marginalement nous faire changer d'avis
est ce que c'est la même chose à la télé
et en radio les débats alors justement
là on touche à quelque chose qui est
très intéressant et qui ont montré
certaines recherches c'est à dire qu' il
n'y a pas du tout la même chose qui se
passe lorsqu'on regarde la télévision
lorsqu'on écoute le débat à la radio à
la radio va surtout retenir des
arguments ou des propositions en
revanche lorsqu'on regarde un débat à la
télévision on va davantage se focaliser
sur les personnalités et sur les
manières d'être des candidats et
finalement sa pointe quelque chose ça
point que le pouvoir est l'intérêt
peut-être de l'image dans les débats
télévisés
lorsque on assiste un débat télévisé
lorsqu'on le regarde on renseigné à
travers les mots à travers ce que disent
par les concerts les candidats mais
aussi on apprend beaucoup de choses à
travers leur façon de se comporter à
travers notamment leur langage contre
corporelle ce qu'on appelle aussi la
communication non verbale ou encore pour
faire encore plus modernes les sauf
qu'il c'est à dire un petit peu la
capacité d'attention la gestion du
stress
l'intelligence émotionnelle et ça c'est
tout à fait intéressant dans finalement
les débats nous apporte des informations
peut-être pas sur le fond mais nous
apporte des informations sur la
personnalité des candidats et lorsqu'on
a affaire deux candidats qui sont
relativement proches sur le plan
idéologique ou politique
ça peut être un élément décisif pour
choisir on va se fonder sur la
personnalité la façon de se comporter
des deux candidats plus que leur sur
leurs propositions qui sont relativement
proches un tout petit mot oui là
emmanuel macron merci déjà attiré qui
refuse le débat avec ses opposants est
ce que au nom des précédents de ses
prédécesseurs est ce que vous trouvez
que c'est voilà acceptable comme
argument bas il ya deux raisons il ya
celle là le précédent les zones ne l'ont
pas fait bon je le ferai et l'autre
argument qui est qui est bien établi si
vous voulez dans la communication
politique c'est que les sortants n'ont
pas intérêt à s'équiper à des débats
parce qu'ils ont la notoriété ils sont
connus reconnus et pourquoi pas faire
alors que ceux qui qui qui qui sans
qu'ils entrent en concurrence avec eux
eux ont besoin de se faire connaître
merci beaucoup thierry vedel j'ai appris
beaucoup de choses concernant ces débats
alors on va sortir de la campagne
présidentielle pour terminer avec vous
isabelle parce que en fait on est tous
très marqué par cette semaine horrifiée
horrifié même par cette semaine en
ukraine et on pense à mario paul cet
hôpital pour enfants bombarder ces ville
anéantie et on sait vous allez nous en
parle et qu'il ya des joyaux du
patrimoine dans ce pays on pense à
odessa notamment qui est fait évidemment
vladimir poutine peut-il bombarder ces
deux villes comme il l'a fait mario à
marioupol et à kharkiv et comment les
les ukrainiens protègent leur patrimoine
et ça va être beaucoup plus dit plus
difficile parce que c'est ces deux
villes ont une place particulière dans
le coeur des russes au dessin d'abord
une ville au bord de la mer noire qui
est considérée comme la perle de de
l'ancien empire russe elle a été fondée
par l'impératrice catherine ii en 1794
avec les plus grands architectes et les
plus grands artistes d'europe et à
conserver jusque là son attachement à la
russie c'est un lieu de villégiature
pour les touristes russes et elle est
aussi connu dans le monde entier pour
son identité singulière son côté multi
ethnique polyglotte sa forte minorité
juive son sens de l'humour sa culture
est aussi son patrimoine et son
architecture ca au dessin sur le le
magnifique escalier de l'opéra qui avait
été tourné plusieurs scènes du fameux
cuirassé potemkine d'eisenstein
est aujourd'hui d'ailleurs les habitants
qui organise depuis plusieurs jours la
défense de cette ville absolument
magnifique protège au sus et ses
monuments et notamment la la fameuse
statue en bronze du duc de richelieu qui
avait été chargé par m in 2 de
développer la ville et qui aujourd'hui
entourée d'une ceinture de sacs de sable
alors sur kiev la rga qui avait aussi la
capitale qui a également une relation
particulière à la à la russie cette
relation remonte à l'époque médiévale du
temps de la rousse de kiev quand
l'actuelle capitale de l'ukrainienne
était le centre du première et a slave
et c'est à partir de cet état cela que
seront créés et la russie et l'ukraine
alors aujourd'hui encore la capitale
ukrainienne habite abrite des des lieux
saints de l'orthodoxie d'eau pour
l'église orthodoxe c'est kif très forte
en russie c'est vraiment qu'il y avait
une ville sacrée mais il ya aussi des
liens politiques le une partie dû aux
personnels politiques russes et
ukrainiens ou en tout cas à moitié
craignant parce qu'à l'époque soviétique
la géorgie et l'ukraine étaient les deux
républiques qui fournissait le plus de
responsables politiques au kremlin
d'ailleurs aujourd'hui une partie de
l'armée russe a aussi d origine
ukrainienne enfin depuis le début de la
crise il faut rappeler que vladimir
poutine passe son temps à dire à la fois
la communauté internationale et a
rappelé aux russes que pour lui
l'ukraine et la russie sont deux mêmes
pays et que les peuples sont un peuple
unique il a donc envoyé ces militaires
se battre contre leurs frères donc on
peut légitimement se dire que dans ces
conditions il n'a aucun intérêt a
intensifié les bombardements contre la
capitale 1 donc on a une forme voilà
d'espoir on peut exclure qu'il en un mot
parce que vous entendez un nouveau
besoin qu'on veut pas que son mari les
termes de cette année l'objectif initial
de blackberry poutine c'était un
blitzkrieg très rapide et pour faire
chuter le gouvernement de kiev il n'a
pas réussi donc aujourd'hui la 3
solution la solution diplomatique
elle est mal en j'ai personnellement
d'une capitulation d'ukraine encerclé
les villes ça prendra du temps et
vladimir poutine c'est que le temps ne
joue pas pour lui il reste la troisième
solution l'anéantissement des villes des
bombardements massifs comme à grozny en
tchétchénie ou à alep en syrie
on aura larsonneur et ex rien on a bien
compris qu'on avait voilà un tyran qui
utilise la terreur merci merci
infiniment à vous deux merci isabelle à
très bientôt ses week-ends profitez bien
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]